They're making moves.
Seems like everybody is.
(alarm clock ringing)
♪ Midtempo R&B music ♪
I wanted to make a difference.
♪
I'm all over this network. I need to have
a say in the future of this place.
What you are asking is unprecedented.
I am unprecedented.
♪
You want that seat at the grownup
table, but it's not your turn, Alex.
Don't forget to shut the door on your way
out.
Boop.
Three, two, one...
(overlapping chatter)
♪ music intensifies ♪
Bradley: We're off the air.
Alex: What's happening?
Someone's in the system.
Get that music turned off!
UBA has been the target of a cyber
attack.
This hack is nuclear.
Certain things may come to light
Did you ever tell anybody?
Personal things that were never meant
to be shared.
Let all the secrets come out!
They did not protect me.
They didn't protect you... But I did.
♪
We are flirting with financial disaster.
(screams)
We need someone with more money than God!
I am offering you a lifeline.
Take the money.
♪
- How well do you know this guy?
- What does that mean?
Do you know how much is at stake here?
♪
This is a chance to create something
better.
But you have to really, really
want it.
It's refreshing to get stabbed in the
stomach instead of the back, so thanks.
♪
Stella: He's making moves.
Corey: Seems like everybody is.
♪
What do you think Stella, you wanna run
this place?
♪
I know I made a huge mistake, but I am
handling it.
Fix it or I will.
You broke every rule! How do you sit in
that chair every night?
♪
It is time to smash and shatter.
Let's burn it all down.
Alex: We should finish what we started.
♪